foreign
she asks would it be possible to use a
student loan to repair my car my car is
paid off I bought it cash but it has
major engine problems and I was told by
the mechanic it would cost nearly three
to four thousand dollars to fix it with
another engine I will need a way to get
to school and eventually work very soon
so will taking out a federal student
loan suffice I do understand that you
can use student loans for vehicle
operation and maintenance since it falls
under the transportation category I just
don't know what to do
George
dicey one so technically when you take a
student loan out they're not monitoring
what you do with that student loan it
sounds like she's saying she's going to
take out a new student loan in order to
do this which is one of the worst types
of loans you could take out because
number one high interest rates and
number two you can't even discharge them
right that's really scary well and
what's crazy is this is a really common
thing right now because you can take out
student loans for your cost of living
and I mean that can be kind of squishy
right because what council's cost of
living a vehicle repair a lot of people
end up shopping I mean there's a lot you
can take out student loans for sadly and
we here all the time from people who did
that and now 10 years later they're
still paying on that loan and they are
stressed out yeah and the student loan
companies they don't care about you
meaning they don't care what you do with
that money because as long as they're
getting that interest they're happy
right so they're not going to sit there
monitoring what you do with it well and
they're paying they're preying on
vulnerable people right like college
students they're college students that's
a great example right we were all broken
college at least most of us and so to be
able to have this like you know pot of
money where it's like hey hey do you
need this it's tempting it's really
tempting so I would not do the student
loan we are not going into debt for this
but here's what we can do we can do more
homework I'm getting a second opinion
from another trustworthy mechanic to
actually see is this a three thousand
dollar repair now I don't know how much
money you have in the bank I don't know
you you said you're working very soon is
there things you can sell do you have
family that might be able to help out
can you borrow a car we've got to get
creative but as long as debt is off the
table then we can actually come up with
some different ideas but the solution
here is not let's go take out a student
loan to get back on the road well and
that's the key taking debt off the table
because it's like a lot of times when
you know that there's a way out when you
know that there's an easy way out then
it's like you don't come up with that
creative thinking but if debt is not an
option you're going to find a way even
if it's hard even if it's not pretty
even if you have to sell something that
you like you're gonna find some creative
way to pay for this and when it comes to
car repair here's a good way to think
about it we get a lot of calls about car
repairs and you got to think about can
you recoup the cost of the repair so if
you have a four thousand dollar car and
the repair is going to cost three
thousand dollars but then the car only
becomes worth five thousand it's not
worth it you may just want to save up
and get a different car altogether and
so we don't know how much she paid for
it we don't know what the value of the
car will be as is if she fix it up and
so there's more homework to do you can
do a lot of research online about the
value of the car KBB repair pal there's
so many resources out there to figure
those pieces of the puzzle out well and
it's not it's not count three to four
thousand dollars that's a scary number
when you need a vehicle to get somewhere
and it breaks down that that's a lot to
think through coming up with quickly but
like you said if you do have to get rid
of that card there are Clunkers out
there for a thousand bucks I mean they
may not be great the AC may be a little
bit Shifty
um but they're out there and they can
get you from one place to another so
even if it's it's not a glamorous option
even if it's
um if it's a challenge just remember
it's a season and you can continue to
fight and figure out you know how can
you pay for either the repair or a new
car absolutely